hi my name is dawn Kaena from Prudential
Corporation Asia and I'm here to report
on the result product one of the
sessions which we just get World
Economic Forum here in Jakarta Indonesia
the session was entitled regional
reverberations in responding to
disasters in Asia it was a lively
discussion we had representatives of the
public sector to the private sector and
NGOs we started off with a discussion of
Asia as number one I think of Asia these
days as now becoming number one in a
range of areas including economic areas
the Asia has been number one in
disasters for quite some time over
period time starting 1984 30 years if
you measure it
Asia has about 85% of the world's deaths
related to natural natural disasters
with about 38% of economic damages it
covers the full range of disasters and
the full range of geography in Egypt so
it's clearly a topic which all the
participants are that's extremely
important in an area that's attracting a
lot of attention and good work the the
participants covered a wide range of
personal experience in institutional
experience over the last 10 years in
particular from their perspectives
government in the private sector and
it's very difficult to summarize this in
a short phrase but I think it comes down
to what I would call four seeds first of
all complexity and I think it was widely
recognized by anybody and everybody in
the session that this is an
extraordinary complex issue inside every
sector of society economically you've
got political complexity about
international complexity and so dealing
with this on multiple levels regional
national and local you can imagine which
gets to the second C which is
coordination that really needs to be
tremendous coordination among all those
sectors and levels I think it was the
impression participating but we're
getting better at that but it still
needs to be improved
thirdly community it was very important
that if solutions are going to work they
don't just work at a regional or
national
perhaps what working at the community by
the community LED and market-driven
is a phrase that was echoed throughout
the treatment I think just by everybody
responded it doesn't play at the
community level it really does for
Murphy and finally the spirit of
cooperation that it really takes not
only public secretaries or society but
full participation of the private sector
both in what the private sector how it
conducts its business and also in
activities of corporate social
responsibility to support disaster for
losing preparation for disaster um we
talked about three phases response
immediate response we've talked about
recovery and distillation and finally we
talked about prepping this issue of
resilience and making facilities harder
to damage by disaster making communities
more able to respond in all three of
those phases it was clear that there's a
role for all sectors of society to play
particularly in this final phase of
preparation I think that's an area where
we need to spend more time and more
resources currently only about 0.7
percent of global spending on
humanitarian assistance is going to more
preparation and Risk Reduction that's
not enough either in the evil percentage
terms or absolute rooms that's an area
where we need to provide further support
and attention there were some specific
recommendations about advance
preparations that need to be put in
place so that their materials that
humans and special skills can cross
borders in times of crisis deal with
disasters has not yet come up with with
customs or regulation issues which can
impede the recovery efforts and also we
talked about advance preparation needs
to be done in terms of financial
assistance that there could be each more
attention paid to insurance products for
pre-funding for risk that could be
available quickly in the time and funds
were needed and specifically he talked
about the possibility of some sort of
Asian wine regional facility we call it
Asia disaster bank for a disaster Bank
Asia it would provide short-term funding
or long-term funding specifically
targeted
as making money avail with cases relief
or in longer term finance and deal with
this question of disaster resilient
infrastructure it's a wide range of
discussion excellent input from the